[Music]
welcome back this week
London's flagship Nike store has a new
mannequin on display no it's not some
super fit Olympian style demigoddess
it's a great fat hulking model with
gargantuan thighs and a bomb the size of
Skegness nike says she's there to
celebrate the diversity and inclusivity
of sports sorry but this is a company
that exists to espouse health and
fitness so why is it trying to normalize
obesity with a mannequin who if she was
real
would be well on the way to an early
grave first I'm guessing it's to pander
to the CPC fat acceptance brigade who
are pushing the very dangerous message
that any weight is acceptable even if it
kills you in second as our population
just keeps getting fatter Nike is
desperate to exploit this untapped
market but just as it was dangerous to
promote those skeletal heroin-chic
models on the Paris runways it's every
bit as dangerous to be celebrating
morbidly obese women the obese Nike
athlete is just a big fat lie peddled by
one of the world's leading sports brands
in order to cash in on a crisis that's
killing people
[Music]
Wow you're moving away running the rice
that means go on say somebody's run your
eyes you're not saying it well first of
all Carol you've been very honest and
candid on this show about the issues
you've had with your own way and you've
read a book on this and then spoken
about your journey to losing weight yeah
and exercising and eating better and
failing well that's not what I'm talking
about well I'm talking about the process
right so I'm surprised that you of all
people would be fat shaming I'm not
touching that I hate that phrase so what
is this why why is it why is the concept
of pointing out how dangerous the
obesity is why is that fat shame it's a
ludic so what is it make it's not what
you should be telling wearing positive
to be fair it is demonizing people who
know you'll use that you've used to very
explosive words demonizing and fat
shaming no one's doing any of it well if
you're calling somebody's bottomless
sizes that's it my god is the size of
Skegness as well I'm not I'm not that's
not the point the point is morbidly
obese women are told it's okay they're
told it's Baba okay okay let me finish
so therefore if we're all saying that
being morbidly obese is a health risk it
is surely the best way to deal with that
is to exercise and to start eating well
you need the clothes to do that activity
so isn't that what you're doing up
riding a sir I think to try and deal
with the problem you're I think they're
do you think because because someone
who's morbidly obese sees this Nike
model I don't whether you've seen it or
not yeah I think just because they look
at that that's going to enhance them to
do so it's not you not interested Megan
please so this is a woman yeah who has
been inspired by that model and you'll
actually will be using those clothes to
work out and we have a clip of her let's
see what she has to say shall we yes of
course people of all shapes and sizes
exist they are worthy of being
represented and of course they are
worthy of being catered for mental
health is health as well and when we
harass people when we demean them when
we teach people that they are worthless
based on how their bodies look we are
negatively affecting their health
overall and the stigma that is caused by
fat phobia and by body shaming also
negatively impacts physical health so
there's a much bigger picture here to
consider rather than it's all about
weight and weight alone because we know
it isn't yes less incentivize this this
fat shaming business it's just you know
the figures that the stats and the
figures are quite clear about more
morbidly obese people it triggers
cancers it triggers strokes it triggers
obesity it triggers early death I've got
a support gymnast you you are a good
tabloid journalist your intro was very
punchy but it was incredibly offensive
to some people yes as am I now it
perpetuates the myth that everybody goes
that goes to gyms is like the shape of
general chairman Rachel not the ship and
they're not people need a lot of courage
to go to the gym if they're heavy if
they've got I know that fat chest sort
of if this helps women if this helps
some women actually think oh my god well
done night I am gonna buy those trousers
I'm gonna buy that workout and anything
that persuades someone to actually go
and tackle obesity has to be a good
thing do you think that's why nike are
doing it because they want to help these
people do you think that doesn't matter
obviously one is to sell the equipment
to sell the gear but if that in case if
somebody goes into there and says look
or sees this even this and says hey look
I can get this sort of gear and it
doesn't make me look ridiculous and I
think it's fine I haven't seen that
picture of me blank choice to pay
penalties I feel a bit addiction well
because on one hand we want to encourage
people to get fitter particularly people
who are overweight you guys haven't
totally missed the point if you think
that's what I'm saying what I'm saying
is that this model in Nike is actually
it's not about losing weight it's about
money and it's about pandering
to abrogate a piece
breguet well and exactly what joon-suk
good for Nike for making clothes
available for people who of that shape
and size who want to exercise clothes
Arabic without they're already available
well well good for promoting them listen
you see that the average of Sharon's
what do you think the average dress
sizes in the UK about 16 to 18 it's 16
okay and that's I mean those I wouldn't
have said I think that was about a 16 we
were seeing that that was the size 20
something was it and I say that as a fat
woman that does that as the size 20 no
what can I just say something else about
you you've got an abrupt autocrat an
obsession with fatness but actually have
your men does that fit you you mentioned
skeletal models anorexia as an illness
is a it has got an incredibly high
mortality rate yeah obesity - kills I
think something like 30,000 people a
year and 64% of adults are obese so big
problem but not as desperately worrying
if you're a parent who's got a fat child
to see them exercising is a wonderful
thing if you've got a tight skinny B fat
people shouldn't exercise because you've
all missed my point if that's the case
I'm trying afraid this range of talk
about this wrong talk about the heroin
chic models in the sense that why was
there not the uproar about with that one
that when the hair and [ __ ] one of them
was going on why won't people think oh
that's a positive image to project they
weren't they were saying it was too
sympathetic and but we have we have can
I say we have armies of people now
saying that being being as big as you
like as post okay let me let me just
bring this in quickly so 75% of women in
the UK say they don't exercise because
they worry they'll be judged on their
appearance the very thing that you are
very right thank you for those facts and
figures right there's a long way to go
in the Tory leadership contest and
there's a certain down a street resident
who already seems to have had enough
Larry the cheese
Mouser is a firm feline favorite and one
that all leadership candidates are
desperate to get on good terms with q an
attempt by Rory Stewart who is
encouraged by photographers to pick up
the puss Larry didn't seem keen slinking
out off the grinning hopefuls grasp he
later tweeted it was a good stroke but I
left when I realized the other nine
contenders might be about to copy him
with that cattitude Larry you are are
straight Prowler of the week so should
the candidate have grabbed the pussycat
absolutely if that place is fan base
well done and feed it some whiskers or
win a lot or whatever one gives it go
cat that's what you do there we go
that's it from us for this week of it
don't forget to search for the pledge on
Facebook or Twitter to join in a debate
and you can now also listen to the
program on the go with Apple podcasts
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you